eleven's secret connection to the
monsters of the upside down is finally
revealed in season four with a huge
twist yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and
this is the ending of stranger things
season four part one explained plus
predictions and theories for the second
part and how to defeat bechner spoilers
of course so take care the fourth season
kicks off in horrific fashion revealing
that in 1979 there was a brutal massacre
at the hawkins lab with 11 the only
apparent child survivor this sets up the
idea that l was the one who carried out
the attack and as the season unfolds and
we see her smash bully angela in the
face at the skating rink it's implied
that 11 was exacting revenge on two and
the other test subjects who bullied her
what if i'm the monster eleven's
memories of that fateful day though are
missing so when she reunites with papa
and dr owens at the nina project she's
able to re-experience her early days at
the lab and remembers one of the
orderlies who was friendly to her it
turns out that he is actually number one
and his special abilities were being
suppressed via an implant in his neck
unaware of this eleven pulls the implant
out and he then uses his powers to
lethal effect on a team of gods who've
come to catch them one also snaps the
final god's neck just like eleven did in
season one we're alike you and i eleven
then discovers it was one who
slaughtered everyone at hawkins lab that
day and the reveal is a double twist
because it also turns out that he's
victor creel's son henry the creels had
moved to hawkins and searched for fresh
start for their troubled boy who
teachers and doctors had all described
as broken there he took an interest in a
nest of black widow spiders in the house
and his admiration for them as predators
and gods of our world points to his
megalomaniac desire to rule over and
change the world what's especially
interesting is that henry already
possessed powerful abilities before he
even ended up in hawkins lab and they
don't appear to be the result of any
experiments as he developed his psychic
powers he found he could reach into
people's memories and discover some of
the terrible things they'd done or
experienced in their lives this is
similar to eleven's abilities to perform
remote viewing on subjects across huge
distances such as the russian spy in
season one or when she reached into the
memories of billy's abusive childhood in
season 3. unlike 11 though the creole
boy decided to use his power to punish
his family for what he saw as their
transgressions killing his mother and
sister leaving the blame on his father
who ended up locked away for murder
henry was secretly sent to hawkins lab
where papa decided to exploit him to
recreate his exceptional powers in
others branding him with a number one
tattoo like many interesting villains
the show may be trying to elicit some
sympathy for him when we see how the lab
appears to be abusing him with electro
shock torture however given one's murder
of his family and indiscriminate
massacre at the lab he's clearly
delusional in his thinking that he's
doing good and when he asks elle darth
vader style to join him to take down the
evil emperor brenner you are better than
they are that is why you frightened him
we could re-shape the world remake it
joy and me oh as they face off l tries
to summon the power to resist him using
the advice one gave her to recall a
memory of something that made her sad
and angry something similar to what
carly recommended to eleven in season
two i want you to find something that
angers you so it seems that one may have
manipulated carly as well the advice
though isn't enough for the young l to
withstand one's incredibly strong powers
and as he's about to kill her eleven has
a memory of her own birth come flooding
into her brain
i love you instead of anger it's this
memory of love which gives eleven the
strength to reverse one's imminent
victory and she smashes him through the
glass into the wall behind and follows
it with a nice little superhero landing
by the way brenner had already advised
not to give in to anger a few days
earlier if you allow
anger
or emotion
to invade your thoughts you will fail
the young el then dusts him into the
upside down just like she did with the
demogorgon in season one both scenes are
also an x-men easter egg to jean grey
who defeated the villain mastermind in
this way and the comic book in which
that happened was specifically
referenced in the opening scene of the
pilot episode i'll take your x-men one
three four it was also a cool detail how
eleven sent one crashing through the
mirrored glass into the room behind
foreshadowing how moments later she
literally sends him through the wall
into another dimension and as he tumbles
down bursts of lightning strike his body
transforming him into vechna
this big reveal that juan is wekner more
or less confirms a number of fan
theories that the original test subject
at hawkins lab is connected to the
upside down and it's various villains
like the mind flayer or the demogorgon
and similar to how the mind flayer
monster in season 3 was created by
melting and joining together the bodies
of its victims one mentions a couple of
times how he seems to have absorbed the
people he's killed with each life i took
i grew stronger they were becoming a
part of me they're not gone eleven
they're still with me in here in fact
wekner sometimes asks his targets or
victims to join him as he tries to feed
off their misery or sorrow which reminds
me a little of how pennywise feeds off
people's fear feckner's also connected
to the upside down's hive mind giving
him the ability to spy with any of the
monsters under his control this is
similar to how the mind flayer used will
as a spy in season 2 and billy is a spy
on pawn in season 3. so when steve nancy
robin and eddie cycle through the upside
down on their way to find the gate where
chrissy died a demo bat spots them in
screeches and we see wekner reacting as
he can now track what the group are up
to this is why when nancy tries to go
through the gate to return to the real
world before she can get across vechna
is able to intercept her by entering her
consciousness and putting her under his
curse when nancy falls into wekner's
lair we can see how the villain preys on
his victims fear and guilt over the
traumatic events in their lives so for
nancy she falls into the swimming pool
at steve's house where bob was killed by
the demogorgon in season one this plays
on nancy's feelings of guilt about how
bob died alone at the pool while she was
hooking up with steve inside nancy is
now mentally trapped by vechna akin to
what happened to max when she visited
billy's grave in that case when dustin
and co played max's favorite song it
broke through to her creating an opening
an opportunity to escape max combines
that with recalling happy memories of
her time in hawkins which gives her the
strength to break free of wekner's grip
i expect nancy may need some similar
help given that vechna may also prey on
her guilt over her rekindled feelings
for steve perhaps accusing her of being
unfaithful to jonathan
okay we have to talk about hopper now
that joyce and murray have broken him
out of the russian prison and there's a
huge clue in season four about how
they'll return home now that yuri's
plane has crashed just before that i
want to thank the sponsor of this video
skillshare i often get asked how i
discover all the details and easter eggs
in my videos and a lot comes down to
understanding the nuts and bolts of
filmmaking skillshare have an amazing
array of classes where you can learn all
the techniques and tricks that go into
creating the look of incredible shots
like this one in stranger things for
example this course on cinematography
explains in just 30 minutes how a
professional filmmaker sets the mood
tone and feel of a scene and this
screenwriting class will help you
appreciate and learn how to write a
mind-bending plot-driven film like a
rival skillshare also has a ton of other
creative classes you can take from
photography to graphic design video
editing and character animation so if
you want to pivot your career or level
up your existing skills skillshare is
the perfect resource to beef up your cv
and learn a new side hustle how about
this course on how to launch yourself on
tick tock for example as a very special
offer the first 1 000 people to use the
link or my code flicks will get a one
month free trial of skillshare click the
link below to get one month completely
free okay back to hop although i'm sure
we're all relieved he and dmitry
survived their encounter with the
demogorgon there's still the pesky
problem of how on earth they're going to
get back to the us yuri's plane crash
landed so there's no easy way to get
back to north america however there's a
big clue on one of the season 4 posters
which shows hopper joyce and murray
approaching a gate to the upside down
inside the russian prison we know from
season 3 that the russians opened a gate
themselves in the season 4 sneak peek
there's a shot of hop going through a
door with a flaming weapon and i think
this is him returning to the prison in
search of the gate and armed with fire
in case they encounter the demogorgon in
fact there's a special volume 2 teaser
on netflix that plays right after the
end of the seventh episode credits which
reveals even more hopper details he
enters a room with caged demogorgons
though it's not clear whether they're
alive or dead and then he and murray
stumble upon a glass box filled with
black particulates which appear to be
like the black mist the mind flare used
to possess will in the second season an
interesting detail about hopper's past
came up this season when he revealed new
details about the tragic backstory of
his daughter's death hop explains to
dimitri that when he was in vietnam he
was heavily exposed to age and orange a
chemical used by the us against the viet
cong during the war and hopper goes on
to explain the horrors of what happened
when veterans in the war later had
children kids born stillborn dead in the
womb crooked spines eyes popped out that
last point is especially chilling
because it's the same way that juan or
beckner murders his victims twisting
their limbs and gouging their eyes out
and given the importance of the rainbow
room in the stranger things mythology it
can't just be a coincidence that the
duffer brothers came up with this
particular storyline as agent orange is
classified by the us military as a
rainbow herbicide in other words it was
used in warfare which reminds me of the
times at 11 a product of the rainbow
room has been referred to as a weapon
over the seasons she's a weapon her
baby's a weapon of fighting the commies
in fact the unethical use of chemicals
for military and other purposes is a
recurring theme in the series the
hawkins lab was part of project mk ultra
a real-life cia illegal operation that
experimented with various psychedelic
drugs and other chemicals on subjects as
part of biological warfare research and
in season three both human and rat
victims of the mind flayer consumed
toxic amounts of fertilizer and
chemicals so that their bodies would be
physically weakened and they would break
down and melt easily before becoming
part of the spider monster hopper feels
a huge sense of guilt about the fact he
knew he'd been exposed to agent orange
and still decided to have a baby with
his wife i knew the risk but i hid them
and he believes he sentenced sarah to
death because of this everyone i love i
hurt i wasn't cursed i am the curse and
hop's words here have clear parallels
with how his adopted daughter elle sees
herself as a monster at various points
as well i am a monster hopper's feelings
of gills are likely to come back to
haunt him in the second part of this
season as beckner could easily put him
under a curse by reminding him of this i
also think that eddie could very well
end up sacrificing himself for the group
by the end of volume 2. he specifically
brought up the point that he's not
normally very brave outside of dnd i am
no hero i see danger and i just
turn heal and run however in the season
4 trailer there's footage of him playing
his guitar on top of a trailer and the
upside down with a set of loudspeakers
playing at maximum volume sorry i'm late
sweetheart
beautiful this may be to blast out music
in an effort to break nancy out of her
trance but it's also very dangerous as
it will inevitably attract attention
from the demo bats and in turn wekner
and in the volume 2 teaser there's
footage that reveals nancy seemingly
free with robin and steve in camouflage
some more shots in the trailer and
volume 2 teaser we haven't seen yet are
this one of erica and the upside down
and another of dustin who's also in the
alternate dimension there's this shot of
11 standing in front of the nina project
as it blows up and mrs wheeler and holly
terrified of something comment below if
you have any theories on what might be
going on in these shots there's also the
mystery of will's painting will is
painting a lot but you won't show me
what he's working on maybe it is for a
girl i think there is someone he likes
because he has been acting weird uh
what's that it's nothing it's just this
painting i've been working on we'll also
grab this in the fourth episode before
they have to escape with argyle so it's
clearly important we know will has been
possessed by the mind flayer previously
and he drew a map of all the vast tunnel
network the monster had created beneath
hawkins so i strongly suspect this
painting will hold a crucial clue to
defeating wekner
11 regaining her powers is also surely
crucial to defeating the villain and now
that she's remembered what really
happened at the lab perhaps she'll get
some more answers from brenna she did
briefly regain her powers at one point
but then they immediately disappeared
you didn't think it would be that easy
did you i don't understand i do papa
daughter the eighth and next episode is
titled papa so i expect we'll get some
answers and progress with 11 there there
are a stack more details in season 4 we
need to discuss which i'll do in my next
video so make sure you subscribe and hit
the bell to get notified as soon as
that's ready so movie lovers what do you
think of season 4 so far and what are
your predictions for the final two
episodes out on the 1st of july and if
you liked this video do leave a thumbs
up i really appreciate it bitchin right
yeah yeah bitchin tap left my next
stranger things theory and easter egg
video thanks for enjoying stranger
things with me and hope you have a
marvellous movie loving week yippie kai
movie lovers